okay so you might be wondering does the
world really need another YouTube
blogger and believe me I'm the first to
wonder because what I guess I'm not a
natural extrovert but I decided to go
ahead with this anyway because at the
end of the day I believe that philosophy
deserves to be a bigger thing out there
and well I guess that's what this vlog
is going to be about my name's Emma but
basically everyone calls me Anne I'm 20
years old and I'm living in London
currently but originally I'm from this
place just outside will Chelmsford I'm a
year and my degree into my philosophy
degree at London University
I think everyone looks at you a bit
strange when you say that as though as
if like to study philosophy you need to
be graybeard and trapped like big
sandals or something not there's
something wrong with that I guess it is
a bit weird that I am studying
philosophy it's kind of strange like how
I got into it actually because when the
first in my family to go to university
so my dad manages a warehouse and my mom
will she used to do bookkeeping but that
was before she got really sick quite a
while ago I'm the oldest of three I've
got a little sister who's 15 and then my
little brother he's only 10 I think
people are quite weird about philosophy
I mean I found anyway that generally
people sort of think it's a big waste of
time or something and then it's funny
because those same people see nothing
wrong in just you know spending a whole
weekend slumped in front of the TV
watching I don't know like Britain's Got
Talent
I think when you tell them that you're
studying philosophy they sort of think
it's a bit maybe like self-indulgent and
pretentious and you know they just they
assume that it's just thinking about the
meaning of life or like studying Plato
something I have taken our big loan to
get to University
and yeah that is a worry but sometimes I
just think if you're passionate about
something you just have to go for it my
course has been it's been fascinating so
far I mean not always great but
definitely always interesting it's in
one of those older colleges so in a way
it's quite formal which I think I like
the people are a bit of around a bunch
to be honest but I think I would like to
get to know some of them better there's
only two women which and one of them is
a virtual student and then there's like
15 guys or something it tends to be a
bit like that on courses I don't really
mind that so much I think it's quite
nice to be a girl doing something that
for so long has just been guys so I
guess that's what I'm going to try and
do over the next few months so I think
just talk you guys through one going
through on my course and maybe try and
explain some of the big ideas I'm coming
across or we'll try to anyway and just
try and open people's eyes to some of
the amazing things that are out there
and like the world of philosophy and
well yeah we'll see I guess that's it
for now so tune in next time